problem 110
if candy bars that regularly sell for 40
cents each are on sale at 2 for 75 so
they used to be 40 and now they're going
for 75 cents what is the percent
reduction in the price of two such candy
bars purchased at the sale price
what is the price reduction so before if
i was going to buy two candy bars i'd be
paying 80 cents
and now for two candy bars i'm paying 75
cents
so i'm
saving five cents or i'm getting a five
cent price reduction so they want to
know the percent price reduction so it's
essentially what percent is five cents
of 80 cents right 5
over 80 is equal to
is equal to
what percentage so let's just figure it
out
goes into
5 and actually we could divide the top
and the bottom
make it a little bit easier well let's
just do it
5.00
add some zeros there
so 80 does not go into 50
8 80 goes into 500 so how many times
does 8 goes into it 6 times
right because 8 times 6 is 48 6 times 80
is 480
480 500 minus 480 is 200
80 goes into 200
two times
two times 80 is 160
and then a remainder of 400
it goes into 400 five times
so that's 0.0625 which is the same thing
as 6.25
percent and that is choice well that's
choice b they wrote six and one-fourth
percent same thing
choice
b
problem 111
111 if s is greater than 0
s is greater than 0
and the square root of r
over s
is equal to
s
what is r in terms of s okay so let's
just square both sides of this equation
so you get
r over s right the square root of r over
s squared is just r over s and that's
going to be equal to
s squared we've got to square both sides
of the equation now let's multiply both
sides equation times s
and we get r
is equal to
s to the third
s to the third and it might have gotten
a little bit
right r is equal to s to the third
either way
and that is choice
d
next question
112. they've drawn us a neat little
diagram here
the front
okay
let me see if i can draw what they have
drawn
they do it in a dark color so i'll draw
it oh let me see they have
that's kind of overly bright but it gets
the job done
and then they have
two boxes in in inside of it
looks like that
one box
something like that
and then there's another box in there
looks something like that although it
looks like the same size in the picture
and that they tell us
that this oops
they tell us that this distance is six
feet they tell us that this distance
is eight feet
the front of a six by eight foot
rectangular door has brass rectangular
trim as indicated by the shading in the
figure above okay this green stuff is
brass if the trim is uniformly one foot
wide so that's one foot
one foot wide what fraction of the
door's front surface is covered by trim
so we need to figure out the area that
is essentially green
well the easier thing might be to figure
out the area that's black and then
subtract it from the total area so
what's the area that's black
so
both of these well they don't tell us is
indicated by the shading
well it doesn't matter we could we could
figure it out well there's a couple of
ways to figure out let's just figure out
the area that's green
so first let's figure out i'm going to
do a different
color
so let's figure out
this area
right here hope you can see that
so that area is what
let me actually draw all of the
different boxes and then we can figure
out the areas
and then we have
that one
and then we have this one
and then we have this one right here
okay
so the area
what's the area of this its height is
eight right this is eight
and its width is one so the area here is
8 and so the area here is going to be 8
of this box right here that whole box
what's the width of this well it's not
the whole 6 right because we have 1 here
and 1 here so the width is going to be 4
right it's going to be 4
by 1. so this is going to have an area
of 4. this is the same thing with the 4
by 1 and that's 4 and 4. so all of the
green stuff has an area of
4 plus 4 plus 4 that's 12
plus 8 plus 8
plus 16 is equal to 28
and that is
oh they want to know what fraction of
the door's front surface is covered by
the trim so that's
28 is the amount of square feet covered
by the trim and what's the total surface
area of the front well the total area is
going to be 6 times 8 which is equal to
48 so if you want to know the fraction
that's covered by the trim it'd be 28
over 48 which is equal to let's see you
divide top and the bottom by 4
over 12
7 12 so that's choice
d
next question
if a
a is equal to
minus 0.3
which of the following
is true
okay so they have a bunch of statements
that relate
a i'm just trying to see the pattern in
the
excuse me
what the sneezes okay so all of these
choices all of these choices they're
relating
a
to a squared to a to the third and then
they're putting it in order right
they're saying which of these is the
least then next and then the greatest so
let's just figure it out
a is
minus 0.3
what's a squared
well 0.3 so it's going to be positive
right negative times a negative is a
positive
and then 3 times 3 and we're going to
have two digits behind the decimal right
because 0.3 times 0.3 so it's going to
be positive 0.09
and then what's a to the third well .09
times 0.3
9 times 3 is 27 and we're going to have
one two three numbers behind the decimal
spot so it'd be 0.027
and we have a negative times a positive
so it's going to be a negative so let's
put these in order which of these is the
smallest number
so think about it the smallest number is
going to be the one that's actually the
most negative
so this right here
is the most negative minus .3 is the
most negative
right we can even draw a number line
here you could have
minus
0.3
which is
a
then you have
minus 0.027 which is a to the third
and then you have 0 someplace and then
you have 0.09.09
which is a squared so the correct answer
should be a is less than a to the third
just less than a squared
and that is
a is less than a third is less than a
squared that's choice b
choice b
problem 114 let me switch colors
which of the following is the product of
two integers whose sum is 11. so they're
telling us that x
plus y
is equal to 11 and which one is the
product so xy
is equal
to what
so let's think about it which of the
following is a product of two integers
whose sum
is 11. so this is interesting maybe we
just have to do some experiment
experimentation right now what what two
integers or sum is 11 well you know we
could we could be dealing with
negative numbers here
so let's think about how we can
how we can rearrange this well maybe if
we i'm just experimenting let's see if
we have at y is equal to 11 minus x does
that give us an intuition then x y is
equal to
11 minus x because y is 11 minus x that
equals 11x
minus
x squared
where x is really any integer
see if you put a let's see so 0 if you
put a 1 there
you could you could get a 10
right if you put a
see if you put x right they don't tell
us that they're greater than 0
so let me think about this
so 32
is 8 and 4
26 is 13
and 2
right 32 the only way let me look at all
the choices this one has me temporarily
stumped hopefully temporarily
so minus 42
what are the different ways i could get
there i could get 21 and 2
i could get
7 and 6 but 1 would have to be positive
and 1 would have to be
negative
i could get 14 and 3
times 3
14 times 3 and actually if i have
plus 14 times minus 3
what does that equal to that's minus 42
and then 14 plus minus 3
and that equals 11.
so
it's answer a i wish i could give you a
better an analytical way of doing it
instead of just experimenting with
numbers i was just trying to figure out
what equals 42. let me think of if
there's a which of the following is a
product of two integers whose sum is 11.
yeah i mean i guess a more systematic
way of doing it might have been to just
say you know minus 42 okay what are the
factors of 42
okay let's see it would be 1 and 42
2 and 21
and you could say 3 and 14 and then 6
and 7 and you can say okay if i and
since this is a negative number one of
these has to be positive one has to be
negative so if i were to take
a positive one of one of these and a
negative one of one of these and add
them up can i get to eleven and i guess
that's where your brains say oh fourteen
minus three that is equal to 11. and
luckily it was choice a you didn't have
to go any further but you would have to
do this with everyone from there now you
might want to look at solutions maybe
they have a more elegant solution to
this anyway i'll see in the next video